[Music]
water represents one of the biggest
threats posed by climate change
that's because rising seas stronger
storms and heavier rainfall could
massively increase flooding by the end
of the century
it's already starting to happen and it's
very likely to get worse
catastrophic flooding in western europe
after violent storms and powerful flood
waters destroying entire towns
it's easy to feel overwhelmed looking at
footage like this
it seems like no one has any idea what
to do about this problem so we're just
going to see more and more damaging
floods year after year
but there is one place where it's
possible to imagine a very different
future
[Music]
when you look at the city of rotterdam
the water is in our jeans you could say
we are already working for a thousand
years on this topic
keeping the water out isn't a new
challenge for the netherlands it's a
battle they've been fighting for
centuries
so when the effects of climate change
started to crop up they were like yeah
let's do this we're ready
we traveled to rotterdam to find out how
this city is getting ready for the
future and whether the ingenious stuff
they've come up with will ultimately be
enough to save them
and hopefully the rest of us too
[Music]
when you look at holland
or the netherlands the name the
netherlands already says that we are a
low-lying country
one-third of this country is below sea
level and two-thirds is vulnerable to
flooding
back in the day the only things keeping
the water at bay were the dikes which
are basically just raised mounds of
earth
once every few decades the water would
overwhelm the dikes and cause
catastrophic flooding
and that was just the way things were
until one day in 1953 all that suddenly
changed
53 it was a disaster
i was five years now and i lived on the
farm
there was no radio
so
people didn't know very hard
a powerful storm struck the southern
coast
overwhelming dikes that had been badly
damaged in the second world war
on the morning of february 1st 1953
kosa's father and brother woke him up
and told him what had happened
they say
oh
everything is water and
your mother and sister are down
by the sea
in 1953 almost 2 000 people died and
that was the moment for us we said this
can have happen again
this is time we started making our first
barrier
the flood galvanized the dutch
government to build the world's most
powerful flood defense system the delta
works
it was a series of modernized dams and
storm surge barriers that took more than
40 years to complete
and the final act of the delta works is
the barrier over here the mazlin barrier
made to protect rotterdam
we're looking at the biggest movable
stormtroopers barrier in the world
this is the same size the eiffel tower
so you're looking at an eiffel tower
laying on its side
[Music]
most of the time the barrier stays open
so ships can pass through
when a storm comes along it snaps shut
preventing the storm surge from
traveling upriver and flooding rotterdam
the movable design was radical when it
was completed in 1997
and it's inspired similar structures in
flood-prone cities around the world
if you look at petersburg on russia a
small version of this barrier has been
made over there
and maybe in the future in front of
manhattan you're thinking about a way to
protect that also
so this was the first one and now
smaller versions are coming all over the
world
but the barrier on its own isn't enough
to keep rotterdam from flooding
talking about climate change we see an
increase of more intensive rainfall
we already are facing now and then small
scale flooding so we need more places
where we can store this water
[Music]
arnold molinar is also working to keep
rotterdam dry
not by keeping the water out
but by giving it a place to go
this is the water square and it is
actually you could say a symbol for our
approach how to become climate adaptive
so under normal circumstances this
square can be used
as for example a basketball field
but on days like this it stores excess
rain water and keeps it from flooding
the streets
so it's a multifunctional solution
we want to add quality to the urban
space but in this way we are also adding
a water storage
this is the first water square that we
have been developing but it's part of a
bigger package of measures
an interesting one close by here is what
we call the duck park or the rooftop
park
which is a kind of a long levee of one
kilometer and on top of it a huge green
park
it's storing excessive rain water
because of the green roof
looking at the challenges related to
climate change a lot of people think
it's going to cost us a lot of space and
money
and we try to show that you also can use
it to work on a better city
[Music]
in some ways the dutch are just as
baffled as the rest of us about climate
change
for one thing there's the question of
what happens when sea levels rise beyond
a certain point
the maslint barrier was built to
withstand one meter of sea level rise
and a redesigned barrier could
potentially handle even more than that
but there's only so much that even dutch
engineering can do
beyond two meters it's difficult
we are working on new scenarios suppose
it will be
more than two meters four meters five
meters then what people ask me will you
be moving uh on a certain
moment in time to the higher grounds in
the netherlands i i can't imagine that
that will be a decision
for survivors like coasts on the other
hand it's not so hard to imagine the
worst
nobody will
to realize it that there is the end of a
nice life here i think
we all will be refugees
[Music]
i think in 300 years
rotterdam will still be here
but when the sea level will rise four or
five meters we will have to find
additional solutions any idea what those
would be
maybe on a larger scale invest in
floating and floating districts floating
cities
and that brings us to our final and most
radical solution
my name is coonholtais i'm a water
architect
for the last 15 years we've been
building floating homes in cities that
face climate change and sea level rise
so we have the floating home which has a
floating foundation and it can move up
and down with the fluctuation of the
river but to keep it on one spot we have
these kind of stilts the water will come
up and you will see that the house will
move up up up up and if the water goes
down it just guides it back
100 years ago you see cities start to
grow up with high-rise buildings because
they saw the space in the air well we
see the city has to grow on the water
it's not only about houses it's about
floating apartment buildings floating
roads floating parks all the kind of
urban components you need to make your
city more waterproof
who knows
maybe someday we'll all live in floating
houses
or maybe something entirely new will
come along
preparing for climate change is a tough
challenge
but for the innovators of rotterdam it's
a process of adaptation that never ends
it's not finished our project it keeps
on going it's an ongoing process
i feel safe my children will feel safe
and my grandchildren will also feel safe
but after that you have to think again
you